I was drawn to this topic by a contest
of ideas about the effects of
globalization on labor conditions around
the world and what I noticed was most of
the debate was rested on anecdotes and
that there had been no large effort to
bring evidence to bear on this question
and so I decided to do the research
necessary to bring a broad body of
evidence from a number of countries to
bear to try and answer this question
about how globalization affects working
conditions and labor rights around the
world
yes well the oldest idea of the effects
of globalization on labor conditions
really goes back to international trade
theory where in very brief form the idea
is that free trade leads resources to
move towards their most productive uses
and when they're in their most
productive uses they have the maximum
scope for monetary and non-monetary
compensation so the idea is the kinds of
adjustments that go with free trade
while painful in the short run lead to
improved labor conditions in the long
run the I should say that in recent
years that oldest ideas been countered
to some extent by assertions that
globalization sets off a kind of race to
the bottom and the assertion involved in
most race to the bottom arguments is
that as countries compete to improve the
scale of their exports and to attract
foreign direct investment they will
degrade their labor conditions well I
try to mustard the evidence on the
effects of free trade on the effects of
the International migration and the
activities of multinational corporations
on a set of working conditions and a set
of labor rights the working conditions
that I focus on our usual wages hours of
work and measures of job safety the
labor rights that I focus on are the
four labor rights that are current
we stressed by international
organizations those are freedom of
association non-discrimination abolition
of forced labor and reduction of child
labor Oh a long list of things the I
suppose the broadest findings is at the
end of the 20th century which was
certainly a period of expanded
globalization you find improvements in
all measures of labor conditions both
working conditions and labor rights
secondly when you look at the data you
find that the improvements were greatest
in countries that were open to free
trade and the levels and rate of
improvement in conditions were poorest
in countries that were closest to
international trade unclosed
international trade the effective
economic growth is quite noticeable
basically all measures of working
conditions and labor rights improve when
countries grow and this is important
because the burden of the evidence is
that countries that shift from close
trade policies to open trade policies
grow more rapidly so free trade has an
effect on working conditions by
stimulating the GDP per capita of most
countries free trade also has an
additional effect on labor rights that
is in addition to the improvements in
labor rights that come through trades
improvement of GDP there's some somewhat
mysterious additional effect in
improving these rights another finding
excuse me another finding pertains to
international migration here the
evidence is mostly historical but
particularly from the first wave of
globalization in which there were a few
barriers to international migration the
international migration particularly
across the Atlantic Ocean that occurred
then greatly narrowed wage differences
between Europe and in the United States
nowadays the incentives to move between
countries are at least as great but on
the other hand there are more political
barriers to migration so to some extent
the potential for international
migration to
who's greater world equality is being
forted by the restrictive immigration
policies of many destination countries
also the research found that
multinational corporations on average
are associated with better rather than
worse labor conditions in the countries
they operate they pay higher wages they
have superior non-pecuniary conditions
of employment on average and also when
you look at the patterns of foreign
direct investment you find that most of
the investment flows between countries
that are already quite industrialized
you do not find a pattern of foreign
direct investment flowing towards the
countries with the poorest working
conditions the final finding I guess I
should emphasize pertains to
international labor standards because
part of this debate has argued that we
need a system of strongly enforced
international labor standards in order
to prevent globalization from eroding
labor conditions the findings of my
research are first of all that the
existing system of international labor
standards has not produced advances in
labor conditions really powerful effects
have been the effects of globalization
the reason for that is that while there
is a positive correlation across
countries between the extent to which
they sign on to the labor standards and
the quality of their labor conditions in
effect that correlation reflect reflects
a tendency for countries to sign on to
standards that they have already
achieved rather than sign on to
commitments to change their standards so
one could say that the overall
conclusion of the book is that the
mechanisms of globalization thus far
have proven to be a more reliable method
of advancing labor conditions than the
international system of labor condition
of labor standards well what it says is
that there's no evidence that I've been
able to find in
the data for over a hundred countries
that the race to the bottom of you is
correct is specifically you do not find
that greater export performance is
associated with poorer labor conditions
and as I mentioned earlier you do not
find that foreign direct investment is
attracted to countries with poor working
conditions and very poor labor rights on
on the other hand you do find that labor
conditions are improved in countries
that shift to open trade policies and
that expand their exports and imports
you find that the multinational
corporations that are a part of the
foreign direct investment flows use on
average superior working conditions and
provide superior labor rights to the
local companies that they compete with
in the host countries so what I get out
of this is the original contest is that
the older vision of international trade
theory about how free trade would affect
labor conditions seem to have the bulk
of the empirical support well two very
interesting sorts of responses most the
economists who read it or discuss it
with me says well every economist knows
that and I suppose that's because that
is because most economists are brought
up with international trade theory on
the other hand if I ask the people well
where would you send someone who wanted
to see the evidence on this issue they
agreed there there was no evidence out
there before I have not heard I've not
had extensive feedback from people who
believe the race to the bottom our
argument
most of those race to the bottom
assertions flow from specific anecdotes
and my view is that by and large those
anecdotes are probably true but they are
not typical of the general situation and
I think that's the contribution of the
book it shows that
when you take a broad look at trade and
migration patterns and foreign direct
investment and relate that to labor
rights and working conditions you don't
see the patterns that are implied by
different anecdotes
so these anecdotes as true as they may
be individually just do not adequately
describe the typical situation or
typical relationship between these
forces of globalization and labor
conditions
you